for dark energy now that will bend the
question what's it what's the
spectrometer and what the hell is dark
energy I mean aside from something that
happens at Slytherin house in Hogwarts
right I mean yeah so the question
presupposes one is familiar with a
vocabulary X so what you have here is
when we measure the existence of things
in the universe astronomers over the
years have been quite clever
it was once hypothesized by a
philosopher that we will know where
stars are in the night sky and how
bright they are maybe what color they
are but we will never know what they're
made of so said this philosopher but
philosophers don't really make good
scientist because within a couple of
years after that Proclamation the
spectroscope was invented and the
spectroscope allows you to analyze light
and tell you what kind of chemicals were
glowing in the star that made the light
and so you whip out a spectrum at the
spectroscope and a spectrograph which
records it you aim it at the Sun he say
hey I see the fingerprint of hydrogen
and helium and carbon and nitrogen and
oxygen and iron all these chemicals are
in the Sun because when you burn each
one of those on a tabletop and put a
spectroscope in front of them which is
basically a prism that separates it into
a rainbow in that rainbow is the imprint
of all these different chemicals on the
periodic table of elements and carbon
has its own fingerprint and it's
separate and distinct from iron from
oxygen everybody is showing up at the
party and if you know what they look
like in the lab and you look out to the
universe you say hey this matches
perfectly I have found carbon in the
universe I have found hydrogen in the
universe do you know that helium was
found on the Sun before it was found on
earth and guess what we named that
element that's why helium is named
that's helium because it is of the Sun
okay the Sun God Helios Greek Sun God
right and so all right so we've do so
the spectroscope is powered ticket
to the chemical composition of the
universe and it presupposes that you're
looking at light interacting with atoms
and that light then travels across the
vacuum of space into our lab you guys to
our telescope so now how will so it's so
dark energy okay that's a it's not light
it is not anything we've ever known
about and is that not anything we've
ever otherwise measured it remains a
mystery and so it defies all efforts of
our spectroscopes and our spectrograph
to determine its composition or what it
is or what's driving it or where it came
from or where it's going or where it's
been but we know that it's there because
we see its effect on the universe oh
yeah so we can't see dark energy but we
know it's effects on the universe
because we see its effects on other
things that's correct that's correct and
it is forcing the universe to accelerate
in its expansion right against the
wishes of the gravity of the galaxies
contained therein because gravity would
say just the opposite right exactly is
it it's kind of an anti gravity pressure
of the vacuum of space and it remains a
mystery what it is and then there's
Nobel prizes galore waiting to be handed
that's whatever figures out the dark
energy problem right on yeah okay that
is so cool